i want to test you i want to see you
know what can i make you believe
i want to test your intelligence so the
whole like don't make a dirty joke about
me that whole dirty joke thing is it's
just it's just a form of that it's like
i want to control what you say
and see whether you deal with that
because if you still make that dirty
joke it's actually seen as attractive
right it's how to build it's how you
build sexual tension it's just the
context it's a way it's a form of
control
um they just want to abstract the truth
because then they can again flip-flop we
can say oh you know well
just having fun like women who cheat on
their boyfriends they say that right
we're just having fun it was just a joke
we're just making dirty jokes at the
same time they could also be aroused and
they should actually be serious
they want to deceive you
that's that's the point it's just
abstraction it's a narcissus way of not
being accountable but still having
control because at the end of the day
they will find out where you stand first
and then flip-flop based on that they
want to play games with you that's why
masculine men don't talk in my video
because you're playing into this they're
using what you're saying
to to kind of try and plan how they're
going to approach you
but women love to shame women
right so
if they don't if you've got nothing
to shame a woman for then
that's for her it's
game because if if she knows that you
you're into this and she's in the same
thing but you don't know then she can
shame you because women love to call
women's law
i don't love it i don't understand it
and that's just one of those things
where
if you don't know anything about me then
i can say anything about you this you've
got no comeback
it's a game it's a game it's a game
what do you guys think you like dirty
jokes i love dirty jokes so i don't care
yeah
from that guy who lives next to you
the one that yeah what about if they're
on the way to work
the one running would you
if he was running and shouting him fine
sorry
sexual harassment sexual harassment i
think that would be in a sexual
harassment though wouldn't it by you
okay
whatever whatever okay what if a police
officer walked by at that time and they
saw that would they class that as sexual
harassment i hope not we would have some
real problems
no he's not touching you he's not
harassing you like it just works what
what is the definition of harassment
please
i will look it up give me one second
oh they've got those adverts on the the
post on the underground about staring
yeah i think those adverts are
aren't good at all like his direct
attack on on men it's like
oh the yeah
i love how they act like everyone
everyone's like a rapist
sexual sexual harassment and this is the
weakest definition i've ever seen this
is why women use it so much sexual
harassment is any unwanted sexual
behavior that makes someone feel upset
scared offended or humiliated and is
meant and is meant to make them feel
that way
sexual harassment is a type of sexual
violence the phrase we use to describe
any sexual activity or act that happened
without consent
okay could i be honest i
so where's the line
like women really need to like
make it because like if you don't want
guys to make you uncomfortable then
should guys just not approach you at all
like what do you want but it's like
don't accept that they don't they don't
exist they just want people but stay in
your house don't leave like
or just ignore it or like wear baggy
clothes like you can do something
or like what do you want them women no
chaos
they want a world where they don't have
to be held to any standards there's no
right way to approach women
and that's why you see so many guys just
walking away because it's just too
complicated now
but they're toxic they're toxic
misogynist that is a big issue though
like
i don't know if any of you saw that tick
tock where um a lady posted it saying
that she went to a singles
day and then no men turn up and then
loads of men reacted to it saying look
you've been saying enough you've been
telling us to leave you alone leave you
alone leave you alone and then it
happens while you're complaining kind of
thing yeah
it was actually not true
there were there were people there she
just videotaped the section and tried to
make it look oh really yeah yeah
again the devil loves lies bro lie about
everything life so much you don't know
what's lie or truth then then i then i
tell you what i really want to do why
did so why did you do that well i guess
you start off a conversation you can
bash men you can bash anyone you need to
bring back shame no let's bring back it
was wrong what shame no i didn't
she's all for shame yeah i believe in
shaming
yeah you should be shamed for being fat
being well yeah
that's that's one you should also yeah
you should be ashamed for being a hoe
you should be shamed for putting your
ass on the internet like like
i mean i honestly think culture is where
the women are like the most marriageable
and the most wifey that they have shame
and they know damn well that if they do
certain things they're going to be
shamed by their whole community so they
don't do them yeah that's definitely
true
and because we've removed we've created
slot shaming on all of these things um
of course i'm not an advocate of people
just you know shouting out people's ears
or whatever but there does need to be a
standard where we're literally saying
this is wrong and this is right whereas
people tend to just say oh you know do
what you want everybody has their own
life you know everybody has their own
view but the thing is some of these
things are rude in biology and facts so
we can't actually just say if we feel
this way
then it's okay i like the old ladies
that just don't give a [ __ ] anymore and
will tell you how it is be like yeah
you're a [ __ ]
and there's there's a part of you that
just loves them because you're like yeah
like
because they tell you how it is like
there's a part of people that appreciate
honesty
and that's like modern women don't want
honesty yeah that's a thing in back home
in asia in general i feel like that's
why a lot of people
keep
um
their actions appropriate because
everyone will know and your family will
be shamed you're like it's just not good
to not act with you guys you guys are
the most swiped right on on dating apps
for a reason like
not for real
like i mean honestly like i think that
like asian culture makes better wives to
be honest i think i need to move to asia
bro trust me no no
every every guy i know that moved to
asia came back and was like yo yeah a
lot of guys actually are moving to asia
because it's just like
we
i feel like in the west like women just
don't appreciate men
enough like you need each other like
stop it
like you need each other to survive yeah
they probably move into asia though once
you get that woman you can't bring her
back because you bring it back
you're back to square one
they're trying to stop that in like
sweden or switzerland oh because you're
saying when she comes here she's going
to change yeah of course she's going to
change yeah but um in sweden or
switzerland i think they were like
they're stopping them from going and
getting because a lot of those guys go
to thailand and they marry these like
thai women and the government is the
woman prime minister she was like trying
to cut down on those passports but then
isn't there a high level of prostitution
in thailand
so isn't so
yeah but when you marry someone you're
not sex trafficking
yeah i mean at least they're getting
money for it the girls here basically do
it for free
i mean hinge and tinder is technically
sexual
yeah and i think there's a distinction
between prostitutes and people just
doing it as an everyday thing there's
always been prostitutes for our history
but the standard for women in general
has always been you know yeah if you do
it this way you're categorized as a
[ __ ] or if you do it you know in a
modest way as in with your husband
don't you think you know you're you're
seen as a wife do you think it's kind of
offensive to to kind of imply that
someone getting marrying a thai woman
must have something to do with the sex
no i'm saying because she was saying
sorry i'm saying because she was saying
earlier that in in asian culture
um the morals are super high but i'm
saying that like but like normal people
you have like
that's like
a different demographic
i think south korea like their single
mother hate rate is like crazy
low stupid like i don't remember what it
was but they were comparing different
like cultural trends
and and like i think that's where the
term leftover women came from was
somewhere in asia in asia i think it was
china policy thing
there's so many dudes in china
if you don't get married in china you're
like less left over
they have like because they had the one
child policy and it was all men right
yeah like there's like a huge like
is that because they got rid of like
loads of the girl babies yeah through
abortions
because they wanted work isn't it for
the fields and stuff the traditional
rural people needed people to attend the
farms and stuff
um so well in countries where people are
shameful indecency single parenthood is
very low
because who who
who suffers
when modern women are selfish who
suffers it's the kids
so it's like this culture of not shaming
women it hurts children in the end
because you have all these 304s trying
to be wives they can't be wives so they
leave
and then boom their single parent
household who suffers the children
that's why i i'm really out here
saving society by telling bringing back
bullying and shame because i'm
i'm kind honestly
like can i be honest it's like
i think
women in the west
it's kind of nice to have if you're like
a single mom because you get like money
oh that the government kicks in but like
back home if you don't have a house like
in indonesia if you don't have a husband
what are you going to do yeah so a lot
of women stay yeah but it's like
that you need that like yeah it's good
you're prioritizing the kid over
yourself because because women are women
are bailed out of every bad decision
they make so if they sleep around we
have birth control if we get pregnant we
can get an abortion if we don't get the
abortion we can get child support if we
get married and doesn't work and we
leave we get alimony
so like whatever we do and and also if
you're a single mother you get money
from the government
there's nothing like that for men
so if a woman if a woman's bad with her
money there's women's shelters
so it's like you're paying women for bad
decisions so they're literally paying
you to be a single mom so if you don't
like and and in asia like they shame you
they say like and here they say oh it's
okay you'll find another guy
it's like you deserve love
it's not even ashamed it's a shame on
the family
because you represent your family
but one day the money will run out
though
yeah that's what the money run out like
you need 2.5 million to retire at 65.
that's a lot and and the women own
two-thirds of debt
even though we make less money
that's why
what's why that's why because they
haven't got the money that's why they
get into debt no it's because they make
poor choices
like it would see like this is the
common theme i have with women it's like
a lack of accountability like that like
me spending more money than i have is
someone else's fault it's your own fault
you you can't if you spend money you
don't have then you're an idiot
well yeah that is your vote so it's like
and nobody should bail you out like if
you if you spend more money than you
have then be homeless
if you if you have kids with a guy
you're not married to be homeless
give the kid to the guy so if it's the
other way around if the wife makes more
money
and she decides she wants to leave the
husband she doesn't want the kids yeah
does she have to then pay alimony to the
husband not typically no no but only
three percent of cases men get alimony
three percent in the u.s i don't know
what it is here
men get nothing can we just we like big
up there's you and your own alimony case
because that's that's that's a win in my
opinion that's the top one i'm like dude
you finessed that
it's like adele's x right yeah yeah i
know i think he didn't even get it he
didn't i thought i thought he did it i i
could look it up but i'm not actually
sure
a great example of what happens when a
woman earns more than her partner is in
scarlett johansson in scholar johansson
she's been around for a while she's
probably dated every top guy the reason
she's still single right she's cute
yeah
she's cute she's left over she's left
over that she's dated like every top guy
in hollywood she's out here still single
but she dated um one guy who owned like
some kind of fashion company they had a
relationship he had a kid he was a
stay-at-home dad
they divorced but you know she initiated
a divorce and she was like slandering
him she was like in interviews and she
was like oh just for the working women
out there i'm not gonna go into
etc kind of trying to demean the fact
that he was a stay-at-home dad that's a
great example of the kind of subtle
disrespect that you will get if you're a
stay-at-home dad because naturally they
won't respect you
women can't respect people they have
power over
anything they have power over you
they're like tyrants not they're not cis
narcissists are the same right if they
have power over you in any way they will
use that to their advantage to
manipulate you because they want to see
that the point is to frustrate you
and and they don't give you
any control either like they can't
submit because they think they make the
money they think you're they're better
than you
that's like i tell people that when i
get married like i want like even if i
make if even if i made more money like
i'd want my husband to like deal with
the finances
because like i just
i love it no i just feel like that's a
man's job men are better with money
and like i haven't had a budget in my
life
you know and most guys do they're better
with money typically because it's like
biologically like we're
we we like buy things emotionally or
like we're more influenced by that stuff
like most marketing campaigns are geared
towards women because they know we even
i was just talking to a company like for
um brand deals and stuff and they're
like you need to increase your your
female audience like i'm sorry they
don't like me
men understand from young if you don't
have anything no one's bailing out so
you've got to be wise straight away with
your money because there's no shelter
if you can't pay your rent you're on the
street it's because we can't afford to
not live within reality otherwise it's
over for us yeah and if someone but some
women don't understand that though they
don't understand that that's how men for
men go to they just don't get